New pushback against cancel culture.
And it comes from some prominent liberal figures with J K Rowling,
Gloria Steinem, Noam, Chomsky,
and others signing an open letter published by Harper's calling for openness to
opposing views. Joining me now is Dave Rubin hosted the Rubin report.
Um, it's pretty fascinating this whole episode,
because as soon as the letter comes out, you had people apologize.
I just want to read one of these tweets to you from Jennifer Finney Boylan,
who had signed the letter. And she said, I did not know who else had signed it.
I thought I was endorsing a well-meaning if vague message against internet
shaming. I did know Trotsky,
Steinem and Atwood were in and I thought good company,
but the consequences are mind to bear. And I am so sorry.
So she canceled herself, Dave.
Oh, the web we weave when we decide to cancel everybody, I mean,
look, it's nice. We're all glad to see it. Right.
It's nice to see liberals finally coming around and realizing, Oh,
cancel culture. Isn't about just taking out conservatives.
It might take them out to, uh, but for the record, I've,
there's a couple people who signed this thing. Who've tried to cancel me.
So it's nice.
But ultimately it's just a bunch of words and I don't see the radicals looking
at this thing and going, okay, let's wrap up, cancel culture. If anything,
they've proven here that they're going to keep attacking and people that have
signed it are going to back out.
Do you think that anyone that signed this letter would defend conservatives that
are attacked?
Sure. There's a couple of people on there who would,
and I'm sure there's a couple of people on there who have,
but for the most part, no. I mean, look,
every one of the people that's on that list. When they,
when the mob comes for them, it's going to be the lefty mob.
It's not going to be the Trump supporters.
It's not going to be the scary conservatives or anyone on the right.
It's going to be the lefties that come for their schools that come for their
jobs that come for their homes and their families. So again,
this is them just kind of protecting their last bastion of freedom,
but they should have been protecting a lot of other people before this.
You saw it coming. You wrote the book, don't burn this book.
I wish.
I was wrong, Dana. Honestly, I really do.
Yeah, well, you're not wrong. And you're always welcome here on the show.
We appreciate it. Dave Rubin and hope that Clyde,
your puppy is sitting by your feet there. Thank you.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.